l'appel de 19 présidents de département
en faveur d'un revenu de base pour
répondre à la crise pour faire face
notamment aux chocs de pauvreté due à la
pandémie de coronavirus à 19 présidents
de départements demande la création d'un
revenu universel inconditionnel
ainsi cela dans une tribune publiée dans
le journal le monde
aujourd'hui plus d'un million de
français viennent s'ajouter aux 9
million trois cent mille personnes qui
vivent déjà sous le seuil de pauvreté et
jusque là réticentes au débat la
majorité présidentielle a accepté
d'ouvrir la réflexion pour en parler
nous sommes ce soir avec stéphane rozès
politologue président de la société de
conseil à cap et philippe maurer
économistes bonsoir à tous les deux
merci beaucoup d'être avec vous sur ce
plateau ce soir en direct sur rt france
un revenu universel qui fait son chemin
en tout cas dans le débat ce qui n'était
pas le cas il ya deux ans philippe muray
re pourquoi jusqu'ici le gouvernement y
est très réticent à la création de ce
revenu universel
moi je peux dire ce que j'en parle en
tant qu'économiste ya des gens en france
un revenu minimum d'insertion et un
revenu de base faible 1 250 euros qui
permet de survivre mais pas de vivre
avec 540 euros payé son loyer sa
nourriture et son logement qui était de
dire qu'en fait les choses les gens
avaient une chance de retrouver un
travail
les deux viandes personnes ou rmi on
appellerait ça maintenant au une chance
de retrouver un travail
si on crée un revenu universel de quel
montant d'ailleurs de 800 2000 euros à
très loin du split pour que les gens
vivent confortablement que va-t-il se
passer on va se retrouver avec des gens
qui travaillent qui vont devoir payer
pour des gens qui ne travaillent pas et
puis des gens qui ont vraiment choisir
d'avoir un revenu universel son travail
et qui sera plutôt confortable donc tout
cela me paraît quand même très très
embêtant ça pose des vrais problèmes
les trois majeurs mais qui fonctionne en
fait un échec total à créer de l'emploi
et à empêcher que les gens glisse dans
la pauvreté mais c'est vraiment très
dangereux et réfléchissez dit dans dix
vingt ans les gens pourront choisir pas
travailler qui resteront pendant 10 ans
ou 20 ans on travaille et comment la
société regardera ces gens qu'elle
clivage cela va faire de la société que
va-t-il faire de ces gens à travailler
je pense que le problème est majeur et
qu'il faut pas s'engager là dedans comme
ça faut plutôt recréer de l'emploi
changer complètement une politique
économique qui perd tout le temps alors
on est dans un contexte particulier
contexte de crise sanitaire
faut-il pour autant abandonner cette
idée quel est votre avis stéphane rozès
est ce qu'il faut pour le coup créer une
aide spécifique notamment pour les
jeunes qui sont oubliés du fameux rsa
la singularité de la crise actuelle du
fait de la pandémie
ce qui la distingue très nettement de la
dernière grave crise de 2008 c'est que
ça touche le système productif
du point de vue de l'offre et du point
de vue de la demande puisque le choix
des sociétés a été d'arrêter l'activité
économique de façon variable selon les
pays
mais du coup ça affecte à la fois la
possibilité d'acheter et ça c'est de la
possibilité de travailler tout ça pour
dire que au fond il va y avoir un moment
très difficile comme commençons dès
maintenant à traverser avec
effectivement ça a été dit ou rsa nous
sommes passés de 5 millions et demi à 8
millions de bénéficiaires du rsa
huit cent mille chômeurs en plus
attendus au fond nous avons environ 10
millions et demi de français qui vivent
en dessous de 1000 euros par mois
donc évidemment on peut peut-être le
temps de cette crise de nif de l'offre
et la demande mettre en place un
dispositif une sorte de filet de
sécurité temporaire de sorte d'aider
ceux qui connaissent le plus de
difficultés notamment dans un certain
nombre de professions le sait
les indépendants les artistes ceux qui
ont des métiers liés au tourisme à la
restauration et donc il pourrait être
envisagé effectivement de mettre en
place un dispositif temporaire sans que
s'institutionnalise sur le moyen terme
des formes effectivement d'assistance
karnas préférence doit être la
préférence au travail
là on voit que c'est d'accord avec vous
philippe maurer je vous ai vu un petit
peu objecté à ce qu'il sait diriger pas
du tout d'accord avec lui a déjà il ya
pas eu huit millions de personnes au rsa
je pense que monsieur s'est trompé c'est
deux millions de personnes qui sont au
rsa aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya six sept moins de
chômeurs en plus inscrits à pôle emploi
donc on a un problème à ce monument
c'est d'ailleurs d'autres chômage voit
bien jusqu'à 25 millions de personnes
qui travaillent et qui assigne ans est
versé 8 millions 7,2 personnes ou rsa ou
au pôle emploi voit bien que le taux de
chômage n'est pas depuis % il est
beaucoup beaucoup plus élevé il est
quelque part d'une façon de masquer le
problème qu'on a c'est que si vous
mettez en place vous pourrez plus
offrants faire quelque chose de
temporaire sous prétexte d'aider
temporairement le fait de pouvoir
choisir de ne pas travailler sera un
vrai problème pour autant il faut
absolument aider
l'objectif de la société c'est d'avoir
un modèle économique qui permette
d'apporter chacun apporte quelque chose
à la société
un travail qui est utile à tous et en
échange de sa d'avoir un niveau de vie
dit c'est ça la dignité c'est pas de
recevoir de l'argent qui tombe du ciel
ça ça pose problème pour autant
effectivement la politique économique et
de créer de plus en plus de chômage la
crise de ducobu tu ne fait qu'accentuer
un phénomène qui a déjà lieu pose un
problème majeur mais il faut arrêter de
s'entêter sur cette politique économique
l'europe et hills pour l'euro pour la
finance et à proposer des liens pour
français parce que le vrai problème le
vrai plan de relance qui est gigantesque
et qui est caché c'est le plan de
relance en fait de deux mille milliards
d'euros d'argent public fait par la bc
d'argent public qui est créé qui
imprimait pour les marchés financiers
on donne deux mille milliards d'euros
d'argent public et on veut donner des
miettes aux français
saison 3 or cet argent il va créer
énormément de richesse chez les plus
hauts revenus chez les hauts patrimoines
à la bourse dans l'immobilier des
métropoles il va exclure encore plus de
français et ce modèle est absolument
intenable
il est injustifiable c'est une injustice
faite aux français
je pense que pour ça d'ailleurs macron
ne pourra probablement pas se
représenter
s'il ne changera pas grand chose
d'ailleurs puisqu'il sera sans doute
remplacé par quelqu'un comme xavier
bertrand qui aura exactement le même
politique économique ce qu'il faut c'est
changer complètement de cadres de
politique économie et ne pas faire de
gadgets qui laisseront des traces très
négatives à long terme ce que voulait
dire c'est qu'il y aura les la dette
forcément à rembourser philippe maurer a
de toute manière on a un problème de
dette c'est que là pour économiser
quelques millions d'euros le lit
d'hôpital et de lits de réanimation
en fait on se retrouve avec une baisse
du pib une récession de 11% en france
donc sa portion aux états unis qui ont
beaucoup mieux géré la crise et 5% en
allemagne
donc on voit que pour quelques millions
d'euros d'économies ce qui est
l'obsession européiste dans tous les
services publics qu'ils ont détesté par
les européens on se retrouve finalement
à dépenser des centaines de milliards
d'euros de plus et d'avoir des dettes
absolument gigantesque à cause de sa
poche on voit donc l'ineptie cette
politique économique mais dernière chose
qui est important c'est que cette dette
publique
en fait qui est détenue par la banque de
france si on n'était pas dans l'euro
elle pourrait être immédiatement
annulables et on repasserait à 90% des
dettes publiques et on pourrait ajuster
sa dette publique de façon raisonnable
sans faire où le mot pour autant du tout
défaut sur la dette publique senti un
problème de file quelconque relancer
l'économie redonner des marges
nachmanoff en étendard des yeux ceci est
rigoureusement impossible et donc ça
nous pose un problème ainsi qu'à tous
nos voisins européens qui est insoluble
séphane rozès ou 1,8 million de
personnes bénéficient de l'aide
alimentaire et les plus touchés ce sont
les jeunes la moitié des jeunes
représentent la moitié des les jeunes
représentent la moitié des personnes qui
sont en difficulté cette aide dont on
parle n'est pas a priori jusqu'ici en
tout cas destinée aux moins de 25 ans
faudrait-il néanmoins élargir cette aide
aux moins de 25 ans ont trouvé une
solution en tout cas pour ces personnes
qui m'aiment entendre ce malgré les deux
il ya deux débats qui sommes
menés là on parallèle entre nous il ya
un débat sur quelle politique économique
faudrait-il pour la france et au plan
européen
alors est par exemple de la future
présidentielle
et puis il ya d'autre part qu'est ce
qu'on fait maintenant
pour ceux qui sont en difficulté que ce
soit en terme d'insertion dans le monde
du travail
et puis encore une fois des 101 des
situations humaines difficiles avec des
suicides notamment dans les professions
d'indépendance est à dire des personnes
qui ont consacré leur vie à travailler
qui me même sert pour certains d'entre
eux de couverture sociale
donc je pense qu'ils ont été mis en
place
d'être retiré les légitimes de trouver
des formes de baudis positif pour
accompagner
d'autre part sur la question de la
presse on sait y un plan de relance dont
le montant global qui a annoncé cran à
la fois des scènes et la doctrine un peu
changé au plan européen
une partie au plan national mais donc
des dépenses sont déjà gager et hop on
ne sait pas très bien quelle va être la
doctrine du gouvernement parce que
récemment le gouverneur de la banque de
france indiqué qu'avec 120% de dette
publique
il faudrait arriver à des politiques
d'austérité
donc on comprend que la politique de
l'exécutif de la majorité actuelle c'est
de dire on ne compte pas les sauts on ne
compte pas les efforts mais au fond
est-ce qu'une fois que cette passe
difficile sera passée est ce qu'il ne
faudra pas revenir à des politiques
d'austérité ce qui voudrait dire des
politiques de déflation ce qui est
toujours très
dangereux de faire des politiques
d'austérité alors qu'on connaît des
politiques de déflation c'est-à-dire pas
d'inflation et pas de croissance dont on
a vraiment là entre nous à deux sujets
qu'est-ce qu'on fait tout de suite pour
ceux qui sont en difficulté
et puis effectivement des sujets plus de
fonds qui seront les débats de la
présidentielle j'en rajoute d'ailleurs
sur ce qu'il faudrait faire la matière
repenser des questions de souveraineté
notamment de souveraineté industrielle
repenser des stratégies en termes de
filières dont il ya tout un tas de
réflexion qu'il faut mener mais je suis
personnellement inquiet pour la
situation vous avez eu raison de les
citer des plus jeunes
et puis des dé plus en difficulté
souvent là à l'autre extrême les plus
âgés car une des caractéristiques de la
france dans le rapport au marché
d'emploi c'est que ceux qui sont les
plus en difficulté chez nous sont aux
deux bornes en très grande précarité
chez les jeunes très grande difficulté
breda voir des emplois stables et puis à
l'autre bornes au fond des entreprises
et peut-être des salariés qui du fait de
la fatigue et de la souffrance au
travail n'aspire qu'à quitter le plus
vite possible comme cance quand ils le
souhaitent eux mêmes comme les oblige
pas l'activité professionnelle il nous
reste très peu de temps et philippe
ménard dont vous vous craignez justement
que on le voit le gouvernement met
vraiment la main au porte-monnaie pour
il a même accepté
de créer peut-être un filet de sécurité
inconditionnel et universel mais le
problème ce sera là prêt et ça risque
d'être difficile pour les français ça va
être très difficile
ça va être très difficile effectivement
le problème c'est qu'on ai déjà parlé
d'un troisième plan de compliments donc
si on veut aider les français il faut
arrêter avec ces plantes gratuitement
qui détruisent à chaque fois l'activité
économique et faire sa blonde sans souci
alors qu'en fait on détruit des millions
de vie des millions d'entreprises de
débit centaines de milliers de petits
commerces qui sont détruits des jeunes
enfants qui sont avec des masses à
l'épaule et ça ça pose un problème parce
qu'il n'y a aucune solution avec ça ne
peut pas dire qu'on s'occupe des gens
quand on détruit l'activité économique
en faisant ça et c'est là vraiment le
sujet principal
ce qui veux pas pour ce qu'il veut par
contre il faut effectivement aider
temporairement les gens et beaucoup plus
vite qu'on le fait aujourd'hui mais il
faut pas créer par contre un revenu
universel qui ensuite entraînerait la
france dans un monde du non travail et
dans un monde en fait où la france
d'offrir un vrai un parasite des autres
pays finalement qui ne produirait plus
rien et qui donnerait uniquement des
dépenses sociales
voilà pour que chacun puisse vivre sa
vie il n'y mans il faut que chacun ait
un travail
il faut arrêter avec cet échec de
politiques économiques et de la nuit
européenne réclame on en reparlera
évidemment un long moment du coup d
confinement aussi merci beaucoup
stéphane rozès merci à vous philippe
murray d'avoir participé à ce débat en
direct ce soir sur arte france